hey so I'm Charles FASA third year PhD
student in computational neuroscience
and today I want to talk about
Neuroscience books so over the years
many people have asked me what kind of
books I would recommend if I would start
learning Neuroscience or learning
computational Neuroscience from scratch
and I usually hesitate to answer this
question because I personally think
books are not necessarily the best way
to learn computational Neuroscience
because computational Neuroscience is
such a practical subject I think it's
usually better to do for example
projects or start coding online
immediately but I do think books can be
a great supplement towards your learning
and to understand the general consensus
of the field that's why I have curated a
list of eight books that I will go over
today and show you which books I've
personally really enjoyed over the years
in in learning computational
Neuroscience so let's get straight into
it so in general neuroscience and also
computational Neuroscience is a very
broad field you have clinical
Neuroscience cognitive Neuroscience
behavioral nurse science and you also
have for example neuroimaging and single
neuron recordings and these are quite
opposite so that's why before starting
to choose which books you should read I
highly recommend you to ask yourself one
question and that is what do you want to
do with the knowledge in five years so
for example if you want to become a
doctor or work in neurology I would
recommend very different books than if
you want to become a computational
neuroscientist and mainly make models so
part one is a theoretical books that I
have enjoyed in general if you're gonna
read these types of books I don't
recommend you to read them back to cover
because they're usually super long and
really complicated how I usually
approach these books is that I read the
chapter dedicated to words the knowledge
that I want to get so for example if I
want to learn a little bit more about
Auto encoders I wouldn't grab a deep
learning book and read everything from
start to finish but I would read the
dedicated chapter on auto encoders and
if I need some preliminary knowledge I
would also read that chapter so the
first book I want to start with is that
I personally quite enjoyed a theoretical
Neuroscience by Peter Diane and I love
Abbott so this is a really good book if
you are interested in single neuron
recordings and how you make models for a
single neuron and also groups of neurons
so in general the book is divided into
three parts so you have neural encoding
and decoding you have neurons and neural
circuits and you have adaptation and
learning and I personally really liked
the chapter 4 on information Theory
which is about entropy Mutual
information entropy maximization and
also how this relates to neuron spiking
for example and how to maximize the
amount of information without neurons
going absolutely crazy and spiking all
the time so yeah I really enjoyed this
book a good tutorial to go along with
the book to also give you some
computational practice is to go on
neuromatch they have the leaky integrate
and fire model and a tutorial about that
that you can follow along and I think
that's a really good supplement towards
this book because it's also about these
types of models and if you notice that
you enjoy these type of models I would
then recommend to buy the book and not
start with writing the book yeah and I
will link all the tutorials and
everything that I mentioned down below
so you can also look it up so the second
book that I want to talk about is
dynamical systems in Neuroscience is
actually quite similar to the other one
at least the topics that they discuss
are quite similar but if I have to
choose I probably like this one a little
bit better I think the way it's written
is a little bit easier and a bit more
clear for studying because for example
they have these reviews of the important
Concepts which I really like because
then you can just see from the chapter
what you're gonna learn and then dive
into the chapter also they have this
kind of
pictures which I think make it a
relative fun read so in general this
book is all about dynamical systems and
dynamical systems are how multiple
neurons work together in the models they
use for that if you've studied physics
or mathematics you probably know
dynamical mathematics from that but if
you've never studied that it's probably
a bit hard to understand maybe at the
first time so you get these kind of face
planes and this is in 3D and I know the
first time I saw this this was quite
hard to understand but I think this book
explains it really nicely and also for
dynamical systems they also have a
tutorial on neuromatch that I would
highly recommend following and you can
make these type of face planes and see
which type of bifurcations exist and I
think that's a really good intuitive way
to get introduced to this type of topic
and if you really like this type of
topic I would probably get this one as
well then the third book I want to talk
about is the biggest book I have in my
closet probably it's the book I think
all Neuroscience students probably have
so this is more about neuroscience and a
little bit less about computational
Neuroscience it's the principles of
Neuroscience by Eric Kendall at all and
I think if you want to learn anything
about Neuroscience there is probably a
chapter dedicated to it in the book so
for example right now I'm working with
several psychiatric disorders um
patients and I wanted to learn a little
bit more about psychosis so I read the
dedicated chapter about that in the book
so I also want to give you today a
little study tip if you don't want to
buy the books I have discovered this
hack and it's called PDF elements so
what you can do with PDF element which I
really like is you can take pictures of
your books or of certain pages that you
are reading and upload it directly to
PDF elements so with PDF element the
first thing I do is I take a picture of
the page or pages that I want to read
then I import the image page into a PDF
element on my laptop for example and I
change it to a PDF format then I click
the OCR text recognition and then you
can edit and copy the text directly so
at that point I usually summarize the
text or highlighted Etc and then I put
it into my dedicated place in my second
brain in notion if you've seen my video
on second brain I really like creating a
second brain and having most of my
information in a dedicated space and PDF
element really helps me with that so
this way I don't usually buy my
textbooks although these textbooks I
have but a lot of the textbooks I just
leave online and I just upload it to PDF
element and take the parts that I need
and in general you can download PDF
element for free I'll put the link down
in the description below and also if
you're a student and you want to get the
pro version you also have a discount
code that they provide so yeah let's get
straight back to the video so the fourth
book I wanted to talk about is this one
this is for if you're a little bit more
into to computational neuroscience and
you find deep learning really
interesting so it's deep learning by Ian
Goodfellow Yeshua bengio and Aaron
Corville I I'm not sure if I pronounced
that right so in general Ian Goodfellow
is one of the Pioneers in deep learning
he works a lot on adversarial networks
and this book is a really good overview
of everything there is to know in deep
learning I do have to say though it's
not an introductory level book it's
quite difficult to read so I've read the
chapters on auto encoders for example
because that's something I'm working on
right now he has also provided the
lectures accompanying this book on
YouTube so if you want to learn a lot
about deep learning and everything what
I would do is I would take every lecture
that has the accompanying chapter and
then I would go over the chapter and I
watch the lecture for example I think
that's a really good way to go over this
particular book so the last book that I
really liked I found this in a
secondhand shop is that a competitional
brain by Patricia Churchland and Terence
chenowski shenowski I'm not sure
um I really like this brand because it
also Dives a little bit into more the
general idea of computational
Neuroscience like and in general it's
written in a really easy manner there's
a little bit less formulas which I would
recommend if you're not a mathematician
or you haven't done any physics for
example I think this book is a little
bit easier to read and also Patricia
Churchland is still doing research and
she also made this Ted Talk that I
really like so she's also a researcher
that I follow so yeah this I would also
highly recommend so then I want to go to
some more pop science books so I do read
a lot of Pop science books in my spare
time and that is because I think pop
science books are usually a little bit
easier to introduce us to a certain
topic and also to spark our curiosity
because I sometimes think if you dive
straight into to a textbook all joy of
the subjects is just sucked out and
you're left with this really dry
material so I think if you're starting
in the field it's maybe a bit nicer to
start with some pop science books so I
have picked three that I have read over
the last few months I've read many more
but I try to contain myself not to
recommend all of them to you so the
first one is models of the Mind by Grace
Lindsay and I really like her as a
researcher she's a computational
neuroscientist that has also done
extensive work in Ai and I think she's a
really good example of what you can do
with computational Neuroscience she
really talks about different ways we can
model brain structure and certain
processes and all the different models
that have been introduced over the years
so in general one of the main messages
of the book is that most models in
physics or in theoretical AI or all
these things are a lot simpler than what
is actually there in the biological
system which is our brain and she really
discusses different way days we can
approach this problem so I really
enjoyed it the only thing I do have to
say that the book is not a light read I
would almost put it between a textbook
and a pop science book because it goes
into extensive detail of different
historical facts and I personally maybe
would have left it aside because it's
quite hard to get through to certain
chapters but I do think the book really
gives a nice overview of the field of
computational Neuroscience and all the
things that were possible and how we
have gotten where we are today so the
second book that I want to recommend is
consciousness explained by Daniel Janet
and the reason I want to recommend this
book is because a lot of people ask me
in the comments about the problem of
Consciousness and how Consciousness can
arise from our biological brain and I
have to say that this is just not my
expertise or a topic that I'm personally
well versed in that's why I usually
avoid answering these kind of questions
because I think my opinion is as good
probably as yours so in Consciousness
explain Daniel Janet explains his view
of Consciousness and the model that he
proposes to solve the hard problem of
Consciousness so the heart problem of
Consciousness is the problem of
explaining why and how humans have
qualia or phenomenal experiences this is
in contrast to the easy problem of
explaining physical systems that give us
and other animals the ability to
discriminate integrate information and
so forth so in general Danielle Danner
talks about different facets of
Consciousness he starts by a full
explanation of the problem of human
consciousness and so the easy problem
and the heart problem then he gives us
the history of how we have thought about
Consciousness over the last few years
and then he gives his empirical based
Theory and finally he shows how this
Theory matches up to real world examples
so again I do not think this book is an
easy read as well I actually think it's
quite dense and also within the field of
Consciousness because it is such an old
field there are a lot of terms that are
used that if you're not used to
philosophy or this type of speech it's
quite hard to understand perhaps the
first time so if I would tackle this
book as a beginner I would probably read
it chapter by chapter and also try to
watch accompanying lectures that explain
certain problems in a little bit more
detail because philosophy is um as hard
I think as a lot of other topics if
you're not well versed in it so yeah if
you have read the book and you think you
know the answer to the heart problem of
Consciousness I would actually love to
know so put it down in the in the
comments below so the third book I want
to talk about is a book that is a lot
easier and a lot more for beginners
because I also wanted to put an easy fun
light read in here so that's the idiot
brain by Dean Burnett and I personally
really love this book it's super funny I
find and even as a neuroscientist some
of the facts he explained were quite new
to me or a little bit surprising so he
talks about sleep memory intelligence
all of these things
um so he also gives this example of
Phineas Gage which is this really famous
Neuroscience story about a man who got
this Rod to the front of his prefrontal
cortex and with this his personality
totally changed and this was in
Neuroscience a really famous story so in
the book The Idiot brain he also talks
about that and he has many other funny
and really interesting stories yeah and
so with this I want to end the video if
you are missing a book and especially
textbooks that you personally really
like within Neuroscience I would love to
hear so put it down in the comments
below and otherwise see you next week
bye